>> IN OTHER NEWS THAT TONIGHT,
NEW BATCH OF TWITTER FILES
SURROUNDING THE RUSSIA HUGS AND
DEMOCRATS EFFORTS TO OUTRIGHT
LIE OVER AND OVER AGAIN ALL
WHILE THE FBI ABUSED THEIR POWE
TO TOO ILLEGALLY SPY ON TEAM
TRUMP WITH HILLARY BOTTOM PAID
FOR A DIRTY DOSSIER.
ACCORDING FROM REPORTING
DEMOCRATS REPEATEDLY PUSHED A
TOTALLY FALSE NARRATIVE THAT
DEVON NUNEZ 2018 MEMO LAYING OU
WIDESPREAD SPRAYING ABUSES WAS
BEING PUSHED BY RUSSIAN BOX ON
TWITTER.
EVEN TWITTER OFFICIALS SAID THA
THEY FOUND NO EVIDENCE THAT NOO
AS REPORT WAS PROMOTED BY
RUSSIAN POTS NOR WAS THERE ANY
SIGNIFICANT RUSH ACTIVITY
CONNECTED TO RUSSIA.
>> SPECIFICALLY JANUARY 2018,
ADAM SHIFT AND SENATOR DIANNE
FEINSTEIN LIED REPEATEDLY
CLAIMING THE RELEASE OF THE MEM
HASHTAG WAS BEING BOOSTED BY
RUSSIAN TROLLS.
HOWEVER, A COMPLETE LIE THAT WA
FALSE AND EVEN TWITTER IS NOT
SAYING SO.
ACCORDING TO THESE NEW DOCUMENTS
.
TO PUSH THE BIGGEST HOAX IN
AMERICAN POLITICAL HISTORY AND
UP FOR THE RECORD, THIS SHOW
WITH ITS ENSEMBLE CAST OUT THAT
STORY COMPLETELY RIGHT WHILE A
99 PERCENT OF THE MEDIA MOB IT
DEAD WRONG AND LIED JUST LIKE
WHEN I SUPPORTED DONALD TRUMP
EARLY, I GOT THE BEAT OUT OF ME
BY PEOPLE SAYING THEM NOT A
CONSERVATIVE.
HERE WITH REACTION FORMER
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE UNTIL
COMMITTEE DEVON NUNEZ ALONG WIT
AMERICAN FIRST OF THE STEPHEN
MILLER.
>> DEVYN, THAT START WITH YOU.
YOU WERE RIGHT THE CONGENITAL
LIAR LIED WE WRITE THE WHOLE
TIME.
I WISH WE KNEW AT THE TIME.
I WISH WE FOUND OUR EARLIER THI
WENT ON FOR NEARLY THREE YEARS.
>> IT STILL GOING ON.
I THINK IF YOU WERE ACTUALLY TO
HAVE ADAM SHIPPED ON YOUR SHOW,
HE PROBABLY WOULD NOT SHOW UP.
HE WOULD CONTINUE TO SAY IT HE
MET ALL GIVE HIM A FOR HOURS AT
THREE ON RADIO AND ONE NTB.
>> I DON'T THINK HE WILL SHOW UP
.
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED AT 2016
DONALD TRUMP CUT EVERYBODY BY
SURPRISE BY USING SOCIAL MEDIA
SUCCESSFULLY TO WIN THE ELECTION
.
AFTER THAT POINT, OBAMA WENT TO
ZUCKERBERG THEY WENT TO TWITTER
SO THIS WAS PART OF AN ONGOING
PROCESS THROUGH 17 AND 18 THEY
HONOR THE RUSSIA HOAX WAS
EXACTLY THAT, A HOAX.
THEIR GOAL WAS NOT TO SCHEDULE
THE FAKE NEWS BUT TO CONTROL TH
DELIVERY OF THE BIG NEWS WHICH
PLAYS INTO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND I BET IF YOU POLL TODAY HE
WOULD STILL HAVE HALF OF AMERIC
MAY BE MORE THAT WOULD THINK
THAT TRUMP AND REPUBLICANS HAD
SOMETHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA.
IT'S A SHAME.
>> THAT IS REALLY A SHAME.
WHERE THERE THE WHOLE TIME YOU
FOLLOW THIS DAILY AS WE DID.
WE ALL KNEW IT WAS A LIE THERE
WAS NO EVIDENCE OF THAT BACK UP
WHAT THEY SAID.
CONGENITAL LIAR THE DEMOCRATS
THE MEDIA MOB, THEY PUSHED THAT
BODHI CONSPIRACY THEORY AND
RAMMED IT DOWN THE THROATS OF
EVERY AMERICAN THAT I THINK
DEVON IS RIGHT PEOPLE WOULD
BELIEVE IT THESE TWITTER FILES
ARE EXPLOSIVE.
THEY DOCUMENT HOW AFTER A DEVON
NUNEZ COURAGEOUSLY STEPPED
FORWARD AND PUBLISHED THE MEMO
DOCUMENTING A ILLEGAL SPYING ON
THE PRESIDENT.
IT DOCUMENTING THE RUSSIA HOAX
AFTER HE BRAVELY STEPPED FORWARD
.
PEOPLE LIKE ADAM SHIPPED AND
DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND SENATOR
BLUMENTHAL CONCOCTED AND PUSHED
A PONY STORY SUGGESTING THEIR
MISSION POTS WERE PROMOTING THI
TO TRY TO TAINT THE MEMO TO TRY
TO TAINT THIS CONGRESSMAN.
WHAT WE SEE HERE IS A SYSTEMATI
PATTERN WHERE THE PEOPLE WHO
POINT IN SAY RUSSIA COLLISION
AND THEY ARE THE INTERFERING IN
OUR DEMOCRACY THEY ARE THE ONES
SPREADING LIES THAT POISON THE
WELL OF THE AMERICAN REPUBLIC.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO MUST BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
I AM SO GRATIFIED TO SEE THAT
ADAM SHIFT LYING LIAR THAT HE I
HAS BEEN BOOTED FROM THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE BE MET
DEVON AS I LOOK AT THIS, YOU GO
BACK TO 2016 THE ONLY PEOPLE
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
MISINFORMATION THAT WAS HILLARY.
THE ONLY ONE THAT TALKED TO A
RUSSIAN THAT SAID THEY HAD
COMPROMISING DEALS ON TRUMPET
NAKED PICTURES THAT WOULD BE TH
CONGENITAL LIAR ADAM SHIFT.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE THE MONEY
WENT FROM THE COMMUNIST CHINESE
THAT WENT TO THE BIDEN FAMILY
UKRAINE WENT WITHHOLDING A
BILLION DOLLARS INTO YOUR FIRE
PROSECUTOR INVESTIGATING MICE
AND WHO ADMITS HE HAS NO
EXPERIENCE IN OIL.
THE FAMILY THAT'S A GETTING A
$5 MILLION NO INTEREST
FORGIVABLE LOAN THAT'S THE BIDEN
'S OF THE ONES GETTING THE
MONEY FROM RUSSIA'S UKRAINE
CHINA THAT'S ALL THEM.
THE VERY THING THEY ACCUSE
REPUBLICANS OF IT THEY ARE
GUILTY OF.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE QUESTION IS IT NOW, WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN?
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE LA MUSCAT THI
COMPANY.
I THINK WE'VE BEEN SURPRISED
THAT THE ELON HAS BEEN WILLING
TO PUT THIS OUT AND I THINK THE
NEW REPUBLICAN CONGRESS SHOULD
SUBPOENA OR REQUEST FROM TWITTE
THIS INFORMATION SO THEY CAN GO
THROUGH IT IT'S BEEN GREAT THAT
MATT HAS GONE THROUGH IT AND
PUTTING OUT THESE REPORTS.
ALSO IT'S ONLY THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG WE ARE ONLY LOOKING AT
TWITTER AND TWITTER IS A SMALL
PIECE OF THE PIE.
MET OUT WHICH IS FACEBOOK AND
INSTAGRAM THEY ARE THE BIG BOY
ON THE BLOCK.
AND THEY SPENT AFTER DONALD
TRUMP USES FACEBOOK SUCCESSFULL
TO GET ELECTED IN 20 OF 16 DID
AT THE RIGHT WAY BEFORE THEY
WERE SHADOW BANNING AND THEN
THEY TURN AROUND AND START TO
SHADOW BANAS THEY PUT PRESSURE
ON THE TECH COMPANIES AND
ZUCKERBERG PUTS IN OVER
$400 MILLION.
>> IT GETS WORSE.
>> THEY HAVE AN FBI GUY THAT
WRITES A THESIS IN COLLEGE ABOU
HOW TRUMP COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA.
HE HAD SET UP A GROUP OF FBI
AGENTS TALKING TO BIG TECH
COMPANIES EVERY SINGLE WEEK
WARNING THEM THERE MIGHT BE BE
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN IN THE
TWENTYTWENTY RACE AND IT MIGHT
BE ABOUT HUNTER AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO THE INTEGRITY HEAD
OF TWITTER MCQUEEN GOT TO ROLL.